oh you want to know why else i'm feeling
positive i'm about to blow your mind
yeah do you know what today is
i know what it is it's national anti-day
which is huge huge for the
anti-community and we are big advocates
for the anti-community here you have
both two aunties sitting here with
different styles of auntie 100 but both
gorgeous nonetheless i'm more of like a
smothering auntie i'm the cementy you
are the smenty and i am just meet you
where you are auntie and
we'll always be there for you also can i
just say coming down here um and
visiting you and the kids and olivia and
the kids has really um but really
stressed the importance of aunties yes i
feel like i'm here i'm literally helping
everyone i feel like my presence isn't a
burden i feel like when i leave you guys
are to be like you're going to feel it
like
the weight of everything i'm carrying i
i don't disagree and i'm not even being
sarcastic you're not exaggerating dead
circus yeah so happy national
ant day to all the aunties out there
know you are loved you are appreciated
and you are respected